okay so now we have the razer phone
right now in our hands once again and
as many would realize that actually
you're getting the razer phone largely
because of the 120 hertz refresh screen
it looks great in hand and if you have
tweaked it through display settings
there might be a bit of doubts whether
you're actually hitting those numbers so
you do have any option to actually open
up in the
um
i'll say a developer options to have a f
permanent fps counter
on the screen all the time so what you
need to do is actually go to the
settings menu like anything else and we
actually need to go into
uh the settings to actually get
enabled as a developer so like any other
platform okay to go to the build number
and settings so search for it
it did seven times two steps one step
and bam we are now developer
let me enter my pin just one moment
and we are now in developer mode so now
that is unreally enabled you actually
need to go into developer settings
so you should go to developer options
the
app options here we go
and we need to look for
one option
where is it
monitoring here we go
go under developer options
show fps
let's get the focus
and enable that
so we have the fps value here you can
see there's a small little value
70 let's go to the main screen and see
what it is 49
78 it's actually higher than most but if
you actually see it in game and we see
we actually pulls it off
do you mean it's like
a nice smooth feeling